merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre depuis la mise en
place de l'Ame aide médicale d'État
Parel Jospin en 99 les détracteurs de
cette mesure sont toujours les mêmes
l'extrême droite les extrêmes droites de
Le Pen
azemour hier soir le Sénat a voté sa
suppression sans opposition de votre
gouvernement c'est une digue de plus qui
vient de sauter cette suppression s'est
faite sur un fond de cacophonie
gouvernementale le octobre le ministre
dararmmanin se déclarait pour la
suppression de la me ce lundi vous avez
déclaré y être défavorable laame étant
je vous cite un enjeu d'humanité et de
santé publique et ce dans l'attente du
rapport stéphanini Evin ce mardi ici
même après un plaidoyer émouvant presque
pour l'ame après avoir indiqué
l'attachement du Gouvernement à ce
dispositif et marquer son opposition à
la droite sénatoriale la ministre
firmain le baudau s'est totalement
dédite en ém ant un avis de sagesse
synonyme de blancin pour cette même
droite
sénatoriale le soir même son ministre de
tutelle Aurélien Rousseau l'a désavoué
en regrettant cette suppression qu'il
qualifiait de grave
erreur nous partageons l'avis de votre
Ministre le
dernier nous nous élevons contre cette
posture politicienne de la droite
sénatoriale prête à sacrifier la santé
des étrangers et les enjeux de santé
publique dans un calcul électoral
cynique l'ensemble du corps médical est
révolté nos hôpitaux s'en trouvent
fragilisés une certaine idée de la
République sociale est bafouée madame la
Première ministre à quelques heures de
la prévisible suppression des articles 3
et 4 du projet de loi nous n'y
comprenons plus rien sauf à constater la
recomposition de la droite avec votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur à la manœuvre en
conséquence madame le première ministre
quelle est la position officielle de
votre gouvernement sur le devenir de
l'Ame répondre la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Patrick canner vous
avez entamé lundi l'examen du projet de
loi immigration porté par le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald haranin alors vous le
savez ce projet répond à un double
objectif d'une part éloigner plus
rapidement ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester sur notre sol et d'autre part
mieux intégrer ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir alors vous m'interrogez
spécifiquement sur l'ame ma position est
sans ambigué c'est celle de mon
gouvernement qui a été exprimée très
clairement
hier
laame
laame l'ame est un dispositif laame est
un dispositif nécessaire qui répond à un
impératif de santé publique il doit
permettre de soigner les personnes
malades qui sont sur notre sol et par
ailleurs l'ame est aussi une protection
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens car
elle permet de prévenir la propagation
de certaines maladies la prise en charge
for